صوت مؤثر اخر يكسر حاجز الصمت في ايران
يقف بوجه سلطه النظام ويصرخ هذا التمرد لا
نهايه له كلمات جريئه نشرتها الممثله
الايرانيه تراني اليدو سي المعروفه
بدفاعها عن حقوق الانسان والمشهوره بنقل
تفاصيل مقاس الواقع الاجتماعيه الايراني
في افلامها في ساعات اشعلت كلمات القصيده
التي نشرتها تراني ثوره افتراضيه موازيه
على حسابها على انستغرام الذي يتابعها
عليه قرابه ثمانيه ملايين شخص لم تكن
الكلمات وحدها الصوره ايضا تراني قررت
التمرد بصوره لها دون حجاب رفيعه شعارا
حملته الحشود الغاضبه على مقتل شابه مني
منذ منتصف سبتمبر الماضي شعار للمراه
وللحياه والحريه اسقط رموزا كما خلفها
النظام الايراني للسنوات من داخل ايران
انضمت اليدوستي الى هذه الثوره وتعاهدت
بالبقاء في وطنها باي ثمن بطلت فيلم
البائع الحائز جائزه الاوسكار عام 2016
كافضل فيلم اجنبي تلعب اليوم دور البطوله
على ارض الواقع في تحديث وتقف عن العمل
للدفاع عن عائلات السجناء والقتلى
مكرم حناوي العربيه